but also when you were younger you were
a flight attendant so how did I didn't
know that so how did that go how were
people I feel like that's one of the
worst jobs people you get people in
Grumpy spaces you gotta remember this
was 25 years ago oh my gosh people were
so much nicer 25 years ago that is
totally people are miserable now okay
yeah maybe they were faking it back then
though well maybe they're just honest
now every once in a while there would be
that that flyer that was miserable and
uh mean and unkind and deserving of some
sort of punishment and so the real only
punishment I had at my disposal was like
a little a little flyby crop dusting
no
and then just keep going
like who did that to me and I'd be like
not me what not me not little old me I'm
just a flight attendant you're just like
tooting like
it's the grumpy guy who's probably
making him even more grumpy which is
winning you're winning that's amazing I
love that you said tooting tooting I
know I just love that you're a crop
dusting passengers we would have been
friends
that is already funny
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]